[Música]
Francia es como una caja de chocolates
nunca se sabe lo que se encontrará y
cada región tiene su especialidad a
chocolatada
[Música]
en burdeos es la ginette un dulce que
combina sutilmente alcohol y cereza el
chocolatero
conserva más de 400 kilos en sus
reservas
[Música]
la variedad se llama la picada de ojo
es una cereza que es relativamente ácida
entonces a diferencia de una cereza
dulce
permite contar con un tratamiento a base
de alcohol que favorece la
transformación del licor
nio escurrida y Secada cada cereza es
remojada delicadamente en un fondant de
azúcar última etapa que requiere muchas
precauciones cubrir la fruta con una
envoltura de chocolate negro
hay que prestar atención tomándola no
debe quebrarse en el chocolate hay que
sumergir hasta más o menos la mitad del
tallo luego hay que cortar el hilo tal
como puede ver ya no escurre y la
ubicamos delicadamente sobre lentejuelas
conservamos toda la particularidad de la
cereza su tallo de origen la está
en el interior
ciertos fabricantes de pseudoginet usan
cerezas confitadas y tallos en plástico
una vez en la boca la cáscara de
chocolate se rompe liberando el jugo de
cereza y el kirs para el disfrute de los
comelones de burdeos
más al sur en biarritz
son los relieves de la costa vasca los
que inspiraron a los chocolateros para
crear los peñascos de villarritz
un recubrimiento de chocolate con leche
o negro sobre cáscaras de naranja y
almendras tostadas
se puede sentir el buen olor de las
solo dan ganas
son almendras tostadas caramelizadas con
jarabe para que sepan un poco azucaradas
y que tengan un mejor gusto y una
torrefacción para sacar el sabor de la
almendra
hace 20 años
confecciona estos peñascos una técnica
que domina a la perfección es muy
meticuloso No sí es necesario debe
parecerse lo más posible al Peñasco que
está en la orilla de la costa
prueba de que los habitantes de biarritz
adoran su Peñasco durante las fiestas se
producen 12.000 diarios
todavía en el suroeste en moto Bond
durante mucho tiempo se buscó un
chocolate emblemático hasta que esta
empresa especialista de la almendra
confitada decide crear La bala de
motobomba
La bala contiene una avellana
ligeramente tostada recubierta de
chocolate negro con una capa pequeña de
azúcar
estas pequeñas canicas negras
encontraron su lugar en el corazón de
los habitantes de motobomba porque
celebran un episodio de su historia
Cuando en 1621 la ciudad protestante
resistía las embestidas del Rey Luis 13
el católico
habían tropas del rey que estaban en
general agrupadas en lugares
estratégicos había una de este lado de
la ciudad costado oeste
Entonces el asedio empieza y los
habitantes de montoro resisten y al cabo
de algunas semanas un monje español le
aconseja el ejército real disparar 400
cañonazos pero resiste de esta Victoria
nació un chocolate La bala pero también
una expresión tirar los 400 cañonazos
estas balas de chocolate que fabricamos
actualmente y consumimos con mucho gusto
solo entonces hoy en día el símbolo de
la resistencia
un emblema de cacao es también la idea
que tuvo un de estrasburgo
se inspiró de una piedra típica del
bosque de los Bosch
buscamos en el hecho del Río este es un
pedazo de arenisca un amigo vendía
pedazos de arenisca Pequeños pedazos que
buscaban las canteras y vendía eso en la
Plaza de la Catedral la inspiración vino
de esta piedra es decir que reproducimos
fácilmente esta piedra hacemos un
chocolate que se llama la arenisca de
los Borges
al lado de la catedral de estrasburgo
completamente construida con arenisca
Rosa se encuentra el taller de christoff
mille fue aquí donde pulió su receta a
base de pralines es decir avellana y
azúcar de Caña en vez de tener solamente
un haliné básico y solo el sabor de la
avellana y el azúcar tendremos además el
sabor del chocolate
todo ello Crea una especie de ósmosis
que cambia completamente la naturaleza
del producto vamos a sumergir todo esto
bajo la mirada de su aprendiz Kristoff
trata de imitar la apariencia de la
piedra de construcción alsaciana
entonces separamos los pedazos
Ahora tienes la piedra
una piedra en bruto en el chocolate
remojo contenedor untado en este azúcar
colorido con pigmentos naturales nos
acercamos a lo que buscamos es la magia
apuesta exitosa para el chocolatero y su
aprendiz estrasburgo puede sentirse
orgulloso de su emblema de chocolate